what's happening reject nation we're
gonna watch the next episode of wanda
vision today
episode seven guys if you could go ahead
hit that like button that mean a lot and
want you
go ahead and subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next one division reaction is up
i'll make this quick as per use this is
reaction highlights fully
reaction watch alongs will be sticking
with the time code or over at our
patreon page over there we cover many
shows are at the same tier you get the
option for both reaction highlights and
watch alongs included
for a whole bunch of shows look at all
these shows
my goodness it's a total gas over there
am i right people yes i am hopefully you
know
if you don't that's because you're not
there all righty yeah yeah no it all
sincerity thank you to everyone who's
enjoying our patreon page your support
has been
overwhelming lastly gotta thank our
buddy eric over at nerd chronic for
editing this for us
and also for just being a great friend
had a lot of long conversations with him
in the past week and you were just a
great dude so please give him a fall
today
he's an extension of the real rejects in
more ways than one anyway on to the
series
[Music]
did you look at that i changed beanies
magic
one just holds the weight down better
don't attempt your first evan peters
impression ever
on camera this is what the people came
from yeah
this is the reaction you were hoping
that's the recap
which i'm sure there's a little detail
of do they slightly used a different
scene
ultron was in every ship so was mephisto
i love how we make fun of easter eggs
and then we were like
[Laughter]
letting our fear and anger get the best
of us oh no intentionally
expanding the borders of the false world
we created
mom are you coming down soon mom oh this
is like modern family
yeah okay did you see all those hexagons
on her bedspread
whoa oh oh no
who know
[Music]
every shot is a zoom
sugar snaps oh no
if you can't communicate all the milk
misting you could control
these people missing children it's
probably just a case of the mondays
am i right
that lip quiver oh here we go
the song is the office it's definitely
yeah
and it's just wanda oh man what the hell
i'm honestly not created by wanda maximo
actually not 100 sure what show that was
riffing on
let me know let me know
i would love it if evan peters is here
from american horror story freak [ __ ]
completely unrelated you're late for
rehearsal with the escape artist
come on
have you seen your dad do you want to go
look for him well if he doesn't want to
be here there's nothing i can do about
it
oh man she's shutting off i know
don't believe anything that man said he
is not your uncle oh
you were counting on me to have all the
answers right
no answers
everything is meaningless
oh my oh no vision is made of vibranium
they literally inherited tough skin
kid's first nihilism why not
someone needs to be here to take care of
you
fine i promise i won't bite
i actually did find a kid once
softcore male pornography just
meant to look like fish
oh no she's losing the total grip on it
all
i'm fine i'm fine i'm fine
no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
hayward wasn't decommissioning vision he
was trying to bring him back online
that's why he was so focused on tracking
vision
okay that makes a lot of sense here they
are
how many theories are about to be shot
down
major good nerf captain rambo my mother
would appreciate your loyalty
she's not the only one we're loyal to
captain let me show you what we brought
you is this the person who she called
maybe major goodner or
are they simply an ambassador for who
she called
oh yeah whoa seriously that sucked
look uh what is your name your real name
darcy lewis
i love how it's still shot she's not
going anywhere
[Laughter]
dr louise are my children's safe that i
don't know
and who is that imposter pietro beats me
so they've just fully declared that
pietro is not
twice
get a grip wanda oh boy i don't
understand what's happening
do you think maybe this is what you
deserve
what who else you're not supposed to
talk yeah it was nightmare who's the
producer
his cat is kevin feige ask your doctor
about
nexus a unique antidepressant that works
to anchor you back to your reality
oh god oh great gang too
because the world doesn't revolve around
you
[Music]
[Laughter]
or does it oh
nexus
you're quiet agnes
you can't read your mind on the inside
you're quiet
ralph says i should have you tried
telling a 10 year old that his mother is
cuckoo for cocoa puffs
i mean in those terms probably be a
short conversation
oh it's gonna be so bad speed captain
god
thor speed speed captain marvel
[Laughter]
it's our most heavily armored space
rover she's gonna sail right through
unharmed did you look at that they
really got rid richards in the show
[Music]
someone go and help her poor jesus come
on
i love the g-lacing
if i can get through
at least wear your helmet monica
come on photon or spectrum
whoa whoa
all
[Music]
oh you have rewritten all your cells
what the hell
whoa she's got a neo thing going on she
can see he's one with the hex
can she see the spectrum of radiation
why'd you blink i feel like you could
have worked with that
but damn look she's normal yeah for the
mo i mean other than the powers she has
she's she's got she's she didn't warp
or is it just because this is set in
modern times
yeah another red light
wonders lights are ready i think
[Laughter]
what i do know is i've been watching on
the vision for the past
week and it's called wonderful
everyone says it every time but it's
funny to hear that just having
knowledge directly wanda what are you
doing
wonder how did you get in here listen to
me get out of my house hayward was
trying to bring him don't talk to me
wanda no oh no
no no no no
[Music]
he's gonna burn westview to the ground
just to get what he wants don't let him
make you the villain
of doctor strange too
i'll get a clearer sense of agnes now oh
yeah
wonder young lady oh i think you
overstayed you're welcome
young lady wanda right along there
wanda oh [ __ ] don't make me hurt you all
right
oh crap i'm freaking agnes
that's just what i was like maybe agnes
is just
what am i doing here
there you go there you go you just
realized yep
here would you like a cup of tea oh man
nothing better happened to that bunny
you can kill that thing though where are
the twins
oh they're probably just playing in the
basement oh jesus what did you do
she reattached them to mephisto's arms
boys
this is the first mcu horror thingy
oh [ __ ] oh
damn
[Music]
oh really walk through
wanda yeah walk into pan's labyrinth
wanda
ugh free motorbox is back
we are no longer in the one a vision
world give me the whip i'll throw you
the idol oh my god it's like the
underworld
oh my god it's like the underworld
are we going to the hell dimension
that necronomicon or something
you didn't think you were the only
magical girl in town
did you oh my god
i revealed [ __ ] name's agatha
nice brooch nice roach she got back
oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
i knew i recognized that bunny
oh
it was just an act that scene oh an act
oh and i killed sparky too
you [ __ ]
oh my god it's over here why would you
do this to us i thought there was like
15 more minutes late
no i thought we were halfway into the
episode
man that last the scene in the last one
was the only thing that made me go maybe
she isn't just yeah
just because she fooled us all just
because of that act and she had it going
and then they did their little fight
club joker reveal thing but one division
yeah it really did look like
bit me thing we stayed through for the
first time in a while i know
we got so lucky we stayed through oh no
oh [ __ ]
get in there
damn okay so he he probably is memphis
or a nightmare or something right now
either that or he's a poor
reanimated corpse maybe he's a zombie
yeah oh it's gotta be [ __ ] boy all right
so we're looking through the footage
right now okay when she first goes back
into
agatha hartness's home that fly on the
wall
yeah i mean the bunny's kind of a cool
indicator of like magician magic right
but then the fly on the wall
from stuff we've you know obviously been
watching so many easter eggs and stuff
for
theories and getting more research and
background info if this still first
appeared as a fly on the wall
every sign points to it being a fisto
man and then the book here
that could be the dark hold book yeah i
mean it looks different than the last
time i've
seen it at least from agents of shield
and i know it's in the runaways too but
it's this is a different universe and
things are getting rewritten so maybe
this is the mcu official darkhold
what was it mephisto imprisoned himself
as a dark
love for something like that right
called dark love prison
yeah yeah yeah okay so you know magic
book you can do all sorts of stuff you
could read out of it you could put stuff
in the book learn a lot about wanda
vision and memphis doing all that in the
last few weeks it's all coming back in
the nargin here
oh no it's it's gotta be right well damn
you would think they're just dropping
reference after reference
sorry eric voss for any moment i ever
had a slight doubt
i'm sorry mr mephisto is vindicated
god you know it had me going it got to
the point where i was like
maybe this is all just nods that are
certain everyone isn't not
dude maybe someone's just a misleading
crap it's been we all theorized from the
trailers
hey there's been a strong contingency of
people out here being like nah it's
gonna be some kind of scientific
technical explanation
yeah it just had me going especially
after the act that she pulled with
vision that
that was like the best way to throw
people off i think you know that was
such a committed act it had me
like so like maybe she's not really i
got the heart just because she sometimes
would go back and forth
seeming very comfortable with wanda to
being scared of wanda
it's all been an act as we saw through
that montage man she was manipulating
so much from beginning to end i gotta
say like what they did with agnes i
thought they handled stronger than some
other
past villain reveals if you look at
captain america winter soldier i
remember when that came
out it was like who's the winner soldier
who's the winner so that's how the
trailers and the movies are
but then it's like he just takes one
google search to be like oh it's bucky
yeah the guy from the first captain yeah
and then it gets revealed and then
you're like yeah yeah
no no yeah yeah but then here it has you
going like some people didn't hold out
at all but then you know people like
myself were kind of going back and forth
at a certain point of like
no for a long time i was believing she's
aggravated the hardness but then right
on episode five i'm like
i don't know man the show's having me
going then maybe there was just some not
yeah yeah so i think like the way they
handled
that reveal of saying like it was her
all along see you guys
yeah it was like okay all right all
right all right marvel you getting your
you guys
got me one yeah yeah and i mean the way
they've been writing these two
suggests that they are so aware of what
we're all going to be doing and saying
in all of these videos yeah
yeah i think they i i gotta imagine they
intentionally wanted us to be teetering
like that
even our homeboy eric boss of new
rockstars at one point was
he was having doubts himself with
someone who went on twitter you know
he's like maybe
i'm sorry maybe it's a 50 50 chance at
this point so marvel did a great job on
the
on the misleading of agnes here i know
there's gonna be people in the comments
should be like i never once doubted it
good for you all right there are people
you win the show you win you win
and then even with pietro there's a
couple of lines in here about pietro
wanda saying don't believe anything that
man said he's not european he's not your
uncle
uh who is the imposter pietrovision asks
you do see that
in that montage that she has her little
weekly purple magic thingy
all over evan peters on his first
appearance here
and uh yeah he's probably just mephisto
yeah i mean at this point he's got to be
in cahoots with her or he's a zombie
reanimated to do a good thing
although you know the other thing maybe
if he's not mephisto it still could be
this is what i'm still holding out hope
for he is still quicksilver
brought over from another dimension she
is just controlling
heavily manipulated maybe slam bam the
spirit
of pietro from the mcu into him
in some way so he could have some of the
memories or she is just
controlling him in total because clearly
we don't know the extent
of what she's been controlling what
she's been letting wanda control
with that in mind i'm just saying it
still could be quicksilver just under
control he did appear
to monica at the end of this as in
quicksilver form he was under armor you
know
that's true he didn't have a reason to
do that or it just could be setting up
for the next episode for him to go
let me rip off my mission impossible
that's the mcu phase four get ready yeah
i think he has to be something
one of one of the two i'd be very
curious if this does end on a note where
oh no the real big baddie
is agatha harkness this whole time
because i don't know
we got two episodes left right now with
those two episodes would it be a little
much to suddenly bring in mephisto at
the very end
because we only just revealed agatha
harkness here maybe we'll get all this
big explanation
as to oh no this has all been in service
to like mephisto
i thought doctor strange two as
mentioned by scott derrickson forever
ago was gonna have
nightmare in it so i was like maybe it's
nightmare but this all seems to be
pointing to mephisto in the end
all right copper cat's been in here and
now he's getting him knocked just of
course when we have to have our most
important discussion so far of one
division now he's gonna take all the
attention from the comments
yeah even with like the kids being taken
in the end you know that all
links back to mephisto it certainly
seems yeah at one point
she says to uh wiccan penny for your
thoughts episode starts off with like my
head really hurts it's just maybe he's
being called in some way
yeah in the last episode it was like a
connection with his dad
well maybe in this one i mean maybe she
lured him in with the literal do you
want a relief from all those thoughts in
your head come on down here i mean hurt
asking like where are my children that's
just so in line with the comics yes
mephisto i mean just
saying like where are my children is out
of the comic strip you know yeah
just just she kind of loses her [ __ ] a
little bit more in the comic
versus just going where are they you
know yeah that dynamic someone having
removed them and her being very
concerned about that and it had me going
of is wanda trying to keep
vision away but maybe maybe in the end
of it all it was actually agnes trying
to keep him away so she can do
her her unveiling so she's not gonna so
vision doesn't come back in and screw
everything up and
stop her i mean i could see a scenario
of it where she she's the one who's
trying to keep
vision away
[Music]
she's just going through grief this
whole series has been about
grief and you know she's at that point
in the series
where you've been in denial you you feel
like everything's all good and then
you're slowly breaking and now she's
exploring
all the other stages but acceptance of
grief is what's happening right now
we're just going through all them
very much in the abandons sort of just
feeling it all and getting almost
realistic about it she's in blame and
anger and depression and bargaining
that's where she's
hovering around right now and she's just
not in acceptance even though
she's gotten hit with a full dose of
reality i thought that was like really
cool from a visual standpoint when she
goes down
into the basement that she's she's in
the one division world she's within the
hex but even then
it doesn't have the television show
dimensions yeah and it just goes like oh
you're real
this is the reality the letterbox almost
becomes oppressive yeah as we step into
a holy other realm and i love
just the way that they blended the tones
because it was such a seamless
transition into something so very
sinister that starts off it reminded me
of it chapter two the way you have that
scene with jessica chastain in the house
it's like okay things are off and then
okay now we're going to discover just
how off things are
yeah man i thought the visuals were so
good with all the realities crashing
together it's like a symbolic of
when you are going through grief when
you're having such a ping-pong head
space and you have racing thoughts and
it's all being sort of manifested
physically this whole series has been
about grief and i like seeing like this
there's like such a great visual
illustration of it all she even has a
line here about like expanding the
borders of the world recreated and
letting fear and anger get the best of
us
and how like this whole hexagon reality
thing has all just been one
giant metaphor for her grief yeah one
potentially one metaphor for someone
also leeching off of her and helping to
build that grief up
it was like a powerful shocking episode
i mean and then with like the reveals of
everything they have going on they had
the nexus commercial or by no means
experts in we've just heard a lot about
it recently yeah yeah
which you know at least certainly seems
to be alluding heavily more to the
multiverse theory
yes i mean she's the next he's
considered a nexus being in the marvel
universe
i mean and king the conqueror is
supposed to be coming in ant-man he's
considered a nexus being this all
just tying in let me just see if i could
get a proper definition here
so i don't have to worry about like
nailing this down okay so
you type it on google it's
cross-dimensional gateway which provides
a pathway to any and all possible
realities that includes realities
between realities or that i couldn't say
it any more efficiently than excel
yes i mean more than just hinting at the
whole thing with the nexus side
of what's happening in the wan division
series and her being a nexus being all
those things
i love how the commercial was
capitalizing on everything i was just
talking about
you know like you have to feel your
emotions you have to deal with the pain
and it's going to leave with more
depression i love that little
tag of the side effects yeah and that
little also button of like the world
doesn't revolve around you
or does it yeah or the universe whatever
it is
and then on the other side of like the
magical
element to it then you do have your
sci-fi side of things
uh with like monica and hayward i mean
hayward's plan just seems pretty
clear-cut at this point because they're
always saying something odd as if he
wanted wanted to take his body
and i feel like he hayward has to be
directly involved it might
be way too coincidental he's got to be
somehow involved with working with agnes
or mephisto or something like that
where it's like all right in exchange i
get to have vision's body brought back
to life and i get to keep vision that's
just what it seems like right it's
really gonna be way too coincidental of
both daddy plants like hey this worked
out for the
i best vision to be resurrected and it
was i had no idea how wanda would do it
happy byproduct because i was getting
nowhere trying this in four separate
parts
yeah but she needed wanted to resurrect
him which he and that makes more sense
of why
when he was breaking through he wanted
to see what would happen
yeah like did it work did she do it can
she bring him back to being
full force free of the hex yeah freaking
hayward always wear a dick
but monica dude this is big for her big
episode for monica
this was awesome for i mean just that
sequence alone where she's
like forcing her way through the barrier
and coming
oh whoa let's slow down whoa major
reveal of major goodner here
that's right aerospace engineer
the engineer i mean wait she she was
goodner's the aerospace engineer right
is that what the show was saying it's
either that or it's just
like she called the aerospace engineer
the aerospace engineer had this you know
special space vehicle sent over and this
is just the soul
i mean it read to me just based off of
the look of nostalgia like this is who i
called
that big easter egg cameo that everyone
was hoping to see
yeah maybe they were just messing with
like no it's just it's just some
person there are a lot of great people
in the armed service in fact
the vehicle isn't going to do much so
really
don't get too excited because if it was
someone special you'd want that vehicle
to do something
but i mean that sequence was cool
wonderfully captured i loved when it's
halfway between what the real vehicle is
and the other half is the rewriting of
it but monica breaking through the
barrier
i was trying to make out like everything
that was being you know what
okay let's slow down i think if i go to
disney plus we watch us without
subtitles if i go to disney plus and i
and i watch this
and if we put it in subtitles i can
probably hear what's being said
hold on guys no i can't i can't leave
monica
maria was going somewhere important
mommy it's okay i can stay with grandma
and pop-pop
shut up woman
[Laughter]
they have an abusive relationship i
wonder if this that was lashawna lynch
there's no way i'm going baby it's too
dangerous
okay is that from captain marvel or is
this a different statement i remember
that argument about her not wanting to
go into space and then finally i mean
mom yeah
who talks her into it mom maybe i can
meet you okay fly up and meet you
halfway
kind of alluding to when one day she
will be able to fly and then you get a
nick fury's voice okay
only if you learn to glow like your aunt
carol which she is
i don't remember honestly i'm not gonna
[ __ ] you guys i don't remember if
these lines are from
you don't remember everyone's favorite
marvel movie word
for word i don't remember if this is
rummage if that line is from captain
scene and they're messing with us right
what else is said here and you were the
most powerful person i
knew carol's talking here when they were
handing out kids they gave her the
toughest one a couple oh
carol maybe this was i if this is not
from captain marvel maybe this line is
from
when she maybe she was in the hospital
and she's like comforting her and saying
you know when they're handing out kids
they gave her the toughest one
i don't know that's cool you getting the
furious on here you get some larson
dialogue
familial and and uh the context of that
is all impacted by whether or not that
is from captain marvel or that is lines
recorded specifically for this series i
mean but yeah you're starting to get
like these
clear teases of um i mean she has to be
coming spectrum
maria's photon yeah so she's become
spectrum the same person
monica rambo's had several names for the
years the most recent one
spectrum well it's it's kind of funny
watching them kind of work together
because
like one is all magic and then the uh
spectrum is all like electromagnetic
stuff different radiations of the
natural world
i mean she can like fly manipulate
energy too so
but their confrontation i thought was so
good uh monica being like i
i i know what you're going through i
feel it and then i'm in my head going
well there's some big differences
between you guys
have been a bit different but i get what
you're getting at no no i'm i'm
overthinking to monica don't worry i get
what you're saying
um but i love when they confront each
other everyone is frozen
everyone is frozen and uh is one of
those shows we really pay attention to
the background
setting up that tease for the big reveal
which when she's like maybe i
am the villain right then and there and
you see agnes coming out you're like
okay so one is definitely
there's the villain there's one of you
who like see what this episode was
preparing you for we're going to tell
you who agnes is this is
yeah we're going to tell you that i got
the hardness don't worry we're getting
there and
part of that i feel like has to there
has to be something
bigger because you know it's episode
seven and if agnes was behind it all or
whatever
the joke becomes agnes all along or
whatever you know i feel like there's
gotta be more to it and then of course
like with vision
uh teaming up with darcy an unusual pair
that's what i've been waiting for
you know you got darcy here it's it's
just funny like as her as a fan of the
sitcom but knowing the sitcom is based
in a world of reality and
from the emotional standpoint and being
the one to reaffirm like look as weird
and messed up as everything's been
you guys belonged you guys want together
she loves you love you
love real love is very real okay and you
guys have been through a lot
envision getting the phase three recap
of everything that happened to him and
then the phase two
origin tale of how he came into
existence and it seems like this is
him in search of like what is his own
personal identity what is his own true
identity he's always been programmed to
sort of be something and now he's really
in a state
of uh consciousness it's the desire for
free will yeah like that's what has been
happening that's what's been happening
in him he doesn't want to be controlled
he wants to know what the reality is and
he wants the free will and then now it's
even tying more into
his search or his own personal identity
and purpose yeah and it's not the most
captain tragedy of the mcu but like i
really enjoyed that side of the episode
too because while it is not the most
in your face part of the episode i
really like that for
vision's character because vision
especially up until one division is
endgame and and
and infinity wars out comes aside he's a
character that makes you feel very safe
and very comforted because of his
range of abilities and to have him here
in such a place of loss where it's like
he has his virtue and he has his power
but he is very much searching for and
sifting through these shards of
identity i think it's just a really cool
character hook and a fascinating way to
develop that character
this is good it's a damn good one man
abe how are you going
snooper's going to snoop snoopers go
snoop
uh oh i feed her so much i'm going to
she's so
sad when he turns into mephisto
all right guys so what'd you think of
this episode of one division i mean it's
gotta be mephisto
he's gotta be involved if they're
opening up all these doors and they've
made other reference i mean like there's
a scratch reference in here and i mean
there's you know agatha's son nicholas
but there's also just that's satan it's
it's many cultures it's mephisto or
worst case it's nightmare yeah but it's
i think it's obviously
not everyone's asleep wow they went
there hell yeah man what'd you think of
the episode leave your thoughts down
below
thank you to eric and chronic for
editing through the complication of
those highlights i'm sure
subscribe follow him click our
notification bell hit that like button
last but not least
daniel gallagher look guy
i think you know where i'm going with
this daniel
is a pharmacist with being a pharmacist
you know what you should start making
sure your clients get
if they need help with i'm going with
the nexus bit you just
start describing texas all right that's
what i'm trying to say next stop
subscribing
multi-universal crisis all right so yeah
like it's been so long
that you've been part of our patreon
page at a certain point you start
reaching for things to connect with the
patron of the day shout outs
pharmacist nexus it worked appreciate
the shout out
thank you for watching support from us
jeez
you're mephisto